gary tan is one of the top silicon
valley investors of all time he's funded
dozens of amazing startups that i've
covered here on the channel in the past
companies like flexport cruz instacart
and coinbase all received checks from
gary before raising money from other
venture capitalists he invests at the
earliest stages so i wanted to know how
he thinks about building companies
fortunately last time i was in san
francisco we were able to sit down for a
great conversation and answer some
really important questions about
startups hope you guys enjoy the
conversation okay so once you've gotten
into yc how do you get the most out of
yc because it's such a short program
just a couple months walk me through if
you today were
on day one of the latest yc batch what
rules would you follow what groundwork
would you lay to make sure that you have
you get the most out of the program
there's sort of two different ways to
look at it but one is like you want to
raise money right and then the tricky
thing is like that's always been in the
background like people just want to do
it to like raise money yeah and the
funny redirect actually like there are
all these hacks that other people do i
will say that a lot of the people who
just do that like start talking to
investors right away yeah and all of
that it doesn't work in the long term
yeah yeah they fizzle out it's kind of
like a focus on vanity metrics right
investor inbound investor inbound feels
good feels like work and then you know
the dangerous thing right now that i
think people sometimes think is like
well i did yc so then i can have access
to silicon valley yeah and then that
skips the whole process i'm like demo
day is by bar none the craziest most
powerful place to ever raise money
but it's also like the 10 weeks before
are sort of um how you learn how to run
fast actually totally you know the
people who skip directly to trying to
raise money like the second gate they
get into yc miss this completely and
then often they never learned how to run
fast and the company goes in the ground
after they raise money because literally
there's this one thing that i have even
tried to
get into people's heads to teach them
how to run fast and as an individual
investor it's actually not possible for
me to do like i funded things that
precede tried to get them to run fast
didn't work wow and then i got them to
do yc and they were a different company
afterwards actually yeah yeah i mean
that honestly happened to me with my
second time through yc because when i
left the first company soylent we were
50 employees i had almost 10 direct
reports i was a manager and so when i
got back to yc dalton said hey you're in
manager mode you're not in builder mode
i was like oh wait you're right i'm i'm
thinking about hiring agencies to do all
this little stuff and like yeah we have
the money so we could do it but that's
not going to teach me anything i need to
get in and actually talk to people and
be on the ground on the front lines and
go and and figure this stuff out and
start running fast and it really changed
our mindset and you know there's always
this question about oh is yc worth it
it's a you know it's x amount of
dilution or whatever if it works for you
and you flip that switch and you start
running fast you never look back and
that's why so many of the successful yc
founders yeah yeah of course it was
worth it and then i think it's like the
mechanics of it though or like even
picking a particular metric yeah and
then making that metric grow 10
every single week yeah because if you
have like from small numbers if you
can't you know get user numbers that
grow by ten percent yeah
more importantly usually it's uh you
know retained users
like because
users is actually vanity metric retained
users is the real metric yeah yeah
people that actually love your product
and keep using it like you know 10 weeks
in but ideally forever absolutely can
you talk a little bit about work-life
balance during yc because it's three
months it's so easy just to say i'm
going to work 120 hours every single
week is that the best thing to do what
makes sense oh man
the hard part about startups period
though is that like the harder you work
like often it does result in better
results yeah that's the tricky thing i
mean it's not popular to say but
especially pre-product market fit when
you don't have anything especially
you know in the last video we were
talking about startup ideas all sort of
come in waves and for a good reason like
normally there's like some regulatory
thing that just changed there's some
technology cost curve that just like hit
an inflection point it's not a mistake
that um you know when instacart started
there were 20 or 30 other people who
were trying to do exactly the same thing
and i know because i read those yc
applications too
and when you're in that race just
imagine like who's going to run faster
and harder
that doesn't last forever and it's
highly unsustainable to run at full at
full sprint right they call it a sprint
for a reason exactly you literally could
not do that you know yeah long term the
hard part is
when you're that early and it's a race
yeah like sometimes you know if you want
to win that's what it takes yeah uh but
i do believe that post demo day after
you've raised money
you have to switch into marathon mode
yeah totally and we also see this all
the time right we have lots of friends
who they tried to sprint 26 miles and
you just don't make it even five miles
yeah yeah i do think yeah so there's
definitely the element of like cut out
anything that's unnecessary you know
you're not going to be going and getting
brunch on sunday and if it can be
definitely do it do it later but at the
same time like you do want to maintain
your health i remember i still vividly
remember we were living in a run-down
house in sunnyvale and our one release
of the day would be we would just go
throw a football in the street and we
would just go and and talk and we were
still talking about business so it was
almost work but it was it was a little
bit of exercise there's some fresh air
some sunlight and we just got away from
hands on the keyboard which is great and
very important and there's going to be
weeks when you're up late coding but i
think you do have to have some sort of
balance right you know uh ryc batch um
well i just remember coding like 20
hours straight and then going to sleep
and doing it again but then
tuesday nights we'd go to garden street
in cambridge for dinner because we were
the last batch in cambridge summer 08
and then on fridays we would go out for
pizza and beers
and not everyone from our batch did come
out for pizza and beers and the people
who didn't come out their startups died
basically immediately wow yeah and i
don't really know why i think some of it
is that if you
meet other people and like spend time
with them like you just become a part of
that community the community sort of
impels you to like keep going yeah and
then if you're totally isolated you just
lose steam like it's too hard it's like
elon musk says it's uh starting a
company is eating glass and staring to
the abyss of death right yeah like you
know it's what you're you need friends
yeah you need a community you need
people that understand because a lot of
times i mean i know when i started my
first company like my family my my
family is like art people so like they
don't really understand startups and
business and having a community where
that's like fully accepted is just super
super critical that's one of the best
things about yc you've gotten to demo
day
you've worked super hard and you've
built your product every single day
you've gotten those retained users and
maybe you even have a curve a graph
that's up into the right things are
looking good how do you take the most
advantage of demo day you said something
about how demo day is like the most
frantic fundraising environment how can
a startup get the most out of that and
the question that i really want to get
to is obviously the funding markets are
crazy right now there's a ton of money
flowing into the to the
venture capital world broadly how much
is too much to raise after demo day how
do you think about that yeah those are
tough questions there's a lot there
i mean demo day itself what's funny is
it used to be a room and then now it's
all on the screen yeah the good thing is
uh y combinator has a website called
bookface and which is a website that i
actually created when i was there
and uh there was an investor database in
there so i would definitely trust that
investor database yeah um the weird
thing that is sort of happening now is
that it's not really
the money that is the limiting reagent
which is like really crazy to me like
remembering being a founder i remember
it didn't it felt like getting the money
itself was the hard part totally and now
i realize
you know
there is so much money and so many
people are getting funded yeah the
question is more
like can you hire your investors the way
you would hire an executive team sure
and so that's actually kind of the thing
that has shifted i mean that is an
excellent mindset to be in at demo day
in my mind is sure i'm pitching myself
and i'm pitching my startup but really
i'm interviewing investors that i want
to work with because if it works out
you're going to be working with these
folks for 10 years right more so i feel
like there's always a lot of power in
that dynamic of coming into
a conversation or a negotiation as
equals and say sure you're the one that
has the money but i'm the one with the
startup i'm the one with the equity that
i'm selling and the equity is valuable
and it could be worth a lot so i have
value it's not an invitation to be rude
to each other it's an invitation to just
be upfront and even more cordial yeah
exactly
yeah exactly i like what you said about
um sort of approaching it as uh you know
the minds of equals come back together
yeah um and actually frankly like if
investors don't treat you like that then
actually don't take their money yeah
that's just disrespectful like they're
showing you what it's gonna be like to
work with them later one of my favorite
things is when you have an idea as an
entrepreneur and you meet the investor
that's been thinking about that category
for a long time but they haven't seen
what you're working on yeah that's cool
and then you can come to them and say
hey you're already an expert in you know
xyz but i've done z prime
something a little bit different and
then it just fits into their mental
model and they're like they click they
get it they're on board very quickly and
then they're immediately a great thought
partner because they're plugged into the
ecosystem they know how to get you to
other investors or other employees and
they really understand yeah that's a
powerful moment i mean i love those
pitch meetings because i'm like i need
to fund that company exactly like i've
been waiting for this thing yeah yeah i
just haven't heard anyone like actually
solve that last little piece to crack
this but i've known that housing was
going to be an important market or food
was going to be an important market or
i've always wanted to do something in
this state yeah i love that for the
viewers that's that's what you need to
be looking for that's like investor
market founder fit actually totally
totally yeah and i think that a lot of
people obviously they're like the top
tier like you're on the midas list
everyone knows that you know like like
working with gary is incredible but it's
still important to you know
just understand where the key expertise
is and find that alignment and find
oftentimes find the investor who hasn't
done a deal with your competitor totally
i mean just just doing some background
there so but talk to me about the the
different pressures i really want to
understand how you think about pricing a
deal because things have changed so much
and every time you talk to a yc alum
they'll very proudly tell you well back
in my day yeah uh raising at a two
million dollar calf used to be great
yeah it was a 10 million dollar cafe and
that now i i think i saw michael seibel
say that there was a company i don't
think it was i don't know if it's a yc
company but there was a company that
raised at a 1 billion
precede valuation
which is you know who knows that's nuts
what advice would you give to that type
of person this is just a personal family
friend who has a hot deal super sharp
team great traction and they're getting
all sorts of term sheets and they have
something that's a more moderate
valuation from someone who's really
aligned versus a higher evaluation from
someone who's maybe unknown yeah i mean
how do you think about that it's hard
because every business is so different
sure but i sort of assume generally for
any given startup idea there are people
who like you said they did their
homework they've been looking at the
space for a long time and then they have
the connections that are necessary to
get you customers or hire executives or
whatever else yeah you know the ideal is
you find someone like that who also will
give you the valuation you want yeah
um but you know not everyone is so lucky
at that point you sort of sometimes have
to make a decision there are lots of
investors who don't have any of the
things that you know normally you need
to be successful yeah but it is money
yeah and then the interesting thing is
usually if you can
get all of the investors to be
interested in you to give you an offer
all at the same time yeah then you have
the maximum flexibility yeah um so
parallelize don't serialize your
fundraising that's right talk to
everyone at the same time get all the
information be giving out all the same
information to everyone yeah that's
that's important because like it's very
easy to get in trouble where you're
saying like one cap to one investor and
another cap to someone else and it's not
like the world is so disparate that like
nobody talks like everybody talks yeah
i've seen deals sort of dematerialize if
you're not engaging in you know honest
negotiation with people right yeah the
classic adage totally applies here if
you just tell people the truth you don't
have to keep track of what you said
that's a great adage i hadn't heard that
well yeah that's great once the
company's funded obviously we could go
on for you know hours about how to
actually go and build these startups but
i want to know more related to yc what
are some of the ways that the yc network
benefits startups after they've
graduated and after demo day and i want
to know much more about bookface and
some of the experiences that you've had
there since you built the thing yeah
bookface is funny because uh paul graham
didn't want me to build it actually
really yeah he was like could you build
this as a part of hacker news and do it
in ark oh my god and the thing is i'm a
rails hacker you know you know like
javascript and i'm like oh shoot what do
i do so then i just wrote a script that
uh scraped hacker news on the back end
and then you know we really reached this
sort of weird moment in yc i think it
was 2012 or so 2011 or so when there
were more people in the batch
that some it like sort of broke dunbar's
number of 150 sure so before you could
know everyone in the batch because you'd
like to recognize them yeah and then we
started having people sort of pretend
that they were nyc and then other people
in yc couldn't tell yeah so that was
sort of the moment when we said well
bookface is actually a play on facebook
i was like okay well we need something
that allows people to know
identification systems yeah um so that's
why i made it before i left yc i um
built in a forum and it was all
topic-based so people could go in say
who their expertise what their expertise
was and then when people came and asked
questions it would like tag the people
who said they were experts in it yeah i
think that that's still a really
powerful moment where almost any any
company
any executive like any thing you need to
know
you're like more or less one
or two hops away from it once you join
this community and it sort of goes back
to the problem of silicon valley there
are very few people who you can trust
yeah and then what yc does is make sure
that and i remember doing this as a yc
partner if you violate the trust of
someone else who's nyc yeah you're going
to get kicked out yeah actually i've had
to kick people out before for like you
know because you need to be able to sit
down with someone and um instead of
having the classic startup conversation
i mean
founders back here
like you know everyone's had this
conversation where you like just met
this person and like how's it going and
they're like it's great we're killing it
we're killing it yeah everyone has to
say they say they're killing it yeah and
uh you know you might as well not have
that conversation yeah exactly and with
bookface you don't need to do that yeah
and i think that's powerful i have
friends who didn't do yc yeah and that's
one of the things that they really
describe that like the process of being
a founder is very lonely yeah and like
100 you know once i became an alum i
realized like i didn't have that
experience at all yeah you got to pick
up the phone and call so many people
basically anyone from your match will
take your call immediately and even from
the broader network so i want to tell
you my favorite thing about bookface
which is obviously it's really really
helpful for building your company you
can vet investors and meet potential
employees but
it is my super power for when friends
need jobs oh yeah i mean obviously i try
and hire them whenever i can but usually
i don't have head count or they want to
do something else like oh they want to
get into web three and i can just post
them on bookface and boom they're over
there and they're in it and they love it
and they and everyone's like oh john
like you're like such a connector and
i'm like i just have a serious
superpower i just have book face all i
did was i just took your resume put it
up there but i vouched for you and i
wrote a little thing and you know it
described you and i mean i think that's
where we're at in um this moment in
society right like 10 20 50 years ago
even like for thousands of years yeah
we're um capital constrained yeah and
then actually like we're clearly not
constrained anymore just open up
techcrunch and look at what's getting
funded these days which is fine and like
the thing is 95 of the stuff or maybe 50
to 80 percent of stuff isn't gonna work
at all and that's okay yeah but you know
now what we are in deeply short supply
of is actually trust yeah and that's
what like communities like yc actually
create yeah so i i definitely want to
hear how i mean you're the guy that
built bookface it's y combinator's
community how have you benefited from it
personally either just in your own life
or as a vc or when
just really anything related i mean
being a vc i have to say like we found
25 unicorns but a decent number of them
ryc
um or you know what's funny is a lot of
them that aren't yc they were people i
met through the alumni community and
that's the thing like um
if we zoom out like to me yc is the
craziest thing because it is this two
percent acceptance rate yeah one and a
half percent i think is that the actual
number
um but if you trace back all the way to
2005 in the first batch it was always
one and a half percent wow so it was
like a thousand applications for 15
spots or something like that yeah and so
when people look at like a 400
per 400 company batch that is actually a
1.5 acceptance rate and they want to
keep that
constant because if they don't keep it
constant
it means that it's that much harder to
get in yeah but that's also not
maximizing the possible impact on
society that like this community could
have yeah and what that means
is that
it's sort of the front door to
everything else that happens in silicon
valley after like i mean how many years
has it been 17 years yeah yeah and
that's that's the crazy thing to me is
like all the people who you know went
through yc even once like they're the
head of engine you know i think the cto
of lyft like you look at every level of
every company of every startup in the
world yeah and you have yc alums that
are in there now which also means that
we have connectivity yeah to all the
different parts of all the startups in
the world yeah yeah yeah it really is a
remarkable program and it's
yeah it's just been yeah it's been a
great great community so obviously i've
been following you all the way since uh
subscriber number 100
and i remember your story uh the the
video was so awesome about it taught me
so much about mrna vaccines with moderna
uh you know where do you want to go with
this channel
yeah i mean i think that i started the
channel mostly just because i was bored
and i saw that you were having fun on
youtube it looked like a cool it looked
like just a cool new skill to build put
a bunch of skills together but i think
the real the real vision for the channel
over the next like 10 years is to just
increase techno optimism on youtube i
feel like there's a lot of channels that
talk about technology but a lot of them
are extremely critical and they take
that negative view because that's what
the algorithm rewards a lot of times and
that's what goes viral i think that it's
important to consider the human side of
a lot of these entrepreneurial journeys
and that's something that i felt like i
could uniquely bring because i'd been in
the founder's seat and i'd been in the
boardroom and i dealt with vcs and i
knew that there was there was conflict
and drama there but ultimately
everyone in silicon valley was kind of
on the same page about let's build new
technologies and let's solve these
problems using new strategies as opposed
to just like tearing down the latest you
know startup that didn't work so i
thought that being a counterbalance to
some of the negativity around technology
on youtube could be both a white space
and an opportunity for new content
although you're obviously making a lot
of content in that space as well but it
could also do some good in the world so
yeah
so how do you think about
big tech and and techno optimism and
kind of how your role fits into all of
that i mean we get to work with people
who are just like two people in a room
like writing the first version of
software or hardware or like the first
time it was ever done so
i don't think anyone ever no one's in
that room no one tells that story yeah
the story of little tech yeah you gotta
speak truth to power to big tech and
like i think that that's what we need
because tech has become so powerful yeah
but then i think we need to make a big
distinction right right all of the
things that end up pushing forward
humanity they start in you know garages
or you know various you know with no
resources
and then how do we tell that story yeah
and then more importantly how do we make
it big tent so that people who are
watching right now
know hey i'm not different like you know
you and i are not different from you
like we are
all just making our way in society and
then the the thing about what i want our
you know my channel to be and i see that
in your channel is that there's a space
for people like it doesn't matter what
background you're from like you could be
old you could be young whatever right
like there is a way to push forward
society through technology yeah and a
startup just might be the way to do it
absolutely that's a great that's a great
coda to all of this thank you gary thank
you man this is great chatting with you
you're very excited for the next collab
and uh yeah and if you didn't see part
one of this go over to my channel yeah
and uh we'll throw the link in the
description
awesome well thanks for watching this
video if you'd like to go a bit deeper
you should really watch my analysis of
how flexport modernize shipping and
logistics in this video next thanks a
lot